yeah has anyone else think
this episode is so bizarre
what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are here to watch the Mandalorian
season three episode six as always joined
by my doll and Josh is he okay how are you
John I am Interstellar sir how are you I am
Christopher Nolan how are you Michael uh is
the baby okay the baby's okay okay that's
all that matters uh are you guys excited
thank you so much for being here please you know
what to do use the force to leave a like if you
end up enjoying this video as always full-length
and watch alongs re-sync up with your own copy
for the Mandalorian available for super sexy
rejects over at our patreon page thank you to
all her joined just for this show alone but we
also cover a bunch of stuff exclusively over
there as well and I wanted to shout out everyone
who did purchase a shirt of the last daddy here's
an image of it real rejects exclusive over at
shopzeroedition.com in 24 hours it became our
most sold shirt ever I said that for this
episode I'd be wearing my shirt of it and
um I'm here to tell you guys it's a
scam no refunds they were all nfts
t-shirts yeah there it is what went
wrong when I was trying to tell you
earlier what I wanted to do was get Michael
um a shirt as well my gift was real rejecture to
him but it was like Star Wars related and then I
had the wrong autofill information go in there now
uh whoever's living on my old apartment is gonna
get a nice surprise subscribe to the channel now
yeah like what is this I love it I'm peeping it
um but thank you to all who bought one
anyway let's watch this episode [Music]
thank you oh that looks like a mon
calamari ship congratulations [Laughter]
that's how star treky this is
hey didn't the other mandalorians
commandeer that [__] see we've
been commissioned to track you down captain sugath
fire The Blasters you see we
were already hired by a certain
mon calamari Viceroy you absconded
with her son I know it was for love
no I won't go I won't go oh
my we love each other please
you have to go with them no I love you please
go we knew fate was not on who cares about
fate I love you oh man I will always love you
it's so nice more romance come with us Prince
long ride home this is a nice little callback
to the Clone Wars can't imagine wolves will
be happy to see you I'll land outside the fleet's
perimeter probably best if we go in on foot
they don't have any air detection you
will be guided on the assigned path
engaging automated guidance what in the
Disneyland is this fascinating welcome
to the experimental prototype community of
Tomorrow they've taken control of the ship
I guess we're going for a
ride is it Disneyland ride
oh my God is that a monorail
track oh my God it's literally
Epcot I love it the sudden urge to
just leave here and go to Florida
oh my God it's dark 2D2 and dark 3PO Bizarro World
version yeah welcome to plazier 15.
please proceed to your hyperloop pod
all black ever we've got a hyperloop
bring us to the Bay closest
to the Mandalorian Fleet I'm
I'm super jazzed about all this your
presence has been requested by the
leadership please do not attempt to leave the
vehicle this is not a request oh my God oh man
oh it's just like the people mover at
Magic Kingdom do you think we're gonna
have to blast our way out of here yeah
find out look at all those people yeah
there's a surprising concerning lack of people
certainly makes direct democracy easier foreign
more like a Doctor Who and Star Trek episode
that's exactly what it feels like [Music]
join us is that is that Jack
Black it's a party it sounds loud
I hope you like secretions I'm thinking about sips
suffered great
as nobility we fell in love they did nice love is
the theme of this episode perhaps hold the baby
[Laughter]
same I'd like to speak to these privateers
that can be arranged there's just one condition
see The View
deliveries right this way finally a role
worthy of Jack Black's beard a drug problem
completely rehabilitated for peaceful
purposes exclusively we thought okay
I'm serious at first unexpected power
Cycles deleted task Stacks assault
assault our constables are ill-equipped to
confront battle droids battle droids oh my
God our constables aren't even allowed to
carry blasters but you allowed us to be
harmed exactly the people have voted we are
a pluralistic society you are mandalorians
weaponry and armor are intrinsic to your culture
yes nice loophole you see where we're going here
unlike my brethren outside
apologies if that is the
impression I gave what I intended
15 would formally recognize Mandalore as a
sovereign system and petition the new Republic
to recognize it as such there is a benefit
what do you think you had me at battle droids
we're all reprogrammed to serve
the community what is this episode
what in the back of the Future Part Two is this
Mr Fusion
you don't need all these clothes
oh no yes why not turn them all
off who's in charge of that I am
let's finish this voted against any Interruption
enjoy Services they can't live without it citizens
are no longer required to work they can spend
their days engaging Recreation the Arts okay
we shut down the droids our citizens wouldn't
know how to survive dystopian Utopia give us the
list before that you'll have to go to the lower
level and speak to the yogurts oh nuts coconuts
feels gotta have a cousin down there
be a cameo by Charlie Day down there
oh it's so cool to see prequel Eric droids
are all played by Nick Nolte we were sent on
behalf of the duchess and Captain Bombardier to
help you with your Droid problem there's no Droid
problem they're programming them to be this way
you will answer our questions and help us
with our task I have spoken damn I really
do all know each other the droids are not
malfunctioning citizens have been harmed
this is not the case this is not the way
here are the locations of the droids you seek
thank you we are in your debt I have
spoken the droids are looking for [Music]
ah this is wonderful what was
that I've spent time with hug nuts
there's a particular way to communicate
with them why not I have one of my friends
this is awesome that is pretty
cool any of them most suspicious
they all do they all look suspicious wow oh this
is the first time in Mandalore I've ever seen
Finn's flashback we're here on behalf of the
duchess to investigate the Droid malfunctions
[Music]
uh I wouldn't do that if
I were you why why is that
I'm gonna caution I thought
they were just checked out
what are you doing and this
shouldn't phase them oh no yes
are bad boom
that guy walking by re-certified huh
you should have left them alone oh
it's performing wow he's fast run sunny let's go
good use of the Boost
shove that guy
what a strange episode
whoa I'm getting some Terminator
RoboCop Vibes right now
[Music]
a little lead a battle angel
but there's so many oh wow oh jeez
nice bow shot first
actually reminds me of Blade Runner when
Decker was hunting down that one woman drug
chickens pockets for money
what's it say the resistor whoa
and there's an address
divs ah yes the buddy cop
Duo that we didn't ask for
that I always wanted you kicking droids is really
not helpful you got back up you did it your way
now let me do it mine okay this is my way this
is the address this is the address thank you
you're just such a strange episode
look at that juicy motor oil
I love the irony of this I don't think they
get many of our kind here yeah Organics or
sparse around here that spark pad was found on
a rogue battle droid we give out lots of stuff
[Laughter]
full compliance with planetary if you don't
start answering questions I'll yank your
memory circuit and dissect it back at the
lab she just did torture him nobody leaves
you're gonna piss on this bar
you can reason with droids the behavior
is programmed all they do is reason
how's that going oh bitter and Petty I want to
help you want me to pull your hearing sensors
too we don't want to be replaced we still
have a lot to contribute Organics created us
it's the least we can do
you're a real hero
get a spin-off about this
bartender direct democracy
right here reprograms the Droids that
drink here it patches the programming
as the commands of the Mainframe change
okay who's programming the Mainframe it
seems the malfunctioning droids all imbibed
from the same batch of nabente [Laughter]
what morgue I love this so much it's so weird
this is such a strange episode I'm here for it
all the way yes sample please I should have
battled right before your vitamin D is down
the particles are definitely present what
are the chances that they're still active
why don't they use that Droid more often there
you go that's a good question that was the most
effective Droid I've ever seen the collateral
damage Droid these are the sub particles
midichlorians Yes actually nanodroids yeah I
know droids it's writing it's a
message rotate the perspective
it's moth Gideon's signature it's a chain code
you see what I can find out follow the blockchain
they were originally manufactured by the Techno
Union oh chain title says it didn't arrive on
plazier through Droid acquisitions strange
how did it arrive evil these Droids were
ordered by an individual is there a name ahead of
security Doc Brown damn it commissioner Hellgate
no oh god oh I was so invested
in here security cameras for any
potential irregularities this
is the most bizarre episode
and the Nano droids you them to disrupt and attack
you're coming with us are those
droids they are droids everyone freeze
I'll Workforce back into battle droids and unleash
them upon the unsuspecting citizens of plazier
literal kill switch doing there's
no way out commissioner has anyone
else think this episode is so bizarre
this has escalated quite quickly yes
you're a separatist separatist is a pejorative
term oh nicely done support democracy
was a Visionary fascinating
time by the Jedi enforcers
I want to hear more about his
thoughts on counties politics
oh that's so what a funny way let me get
that for you my lady I am so dazzled by
whatever the hell we're watching whatever
drugs they did to conceive of this episode
shrimps afraid it is
despicable [Laughter] me
this planet is unrecognizable since he arrived
I had a feeling you hated me is there no room for
a little bit of forgiveness in a galaxy so vast
sorry to have disappointed you my lady
perhaps someday I can earned
such forgiveness I don't think so
as for now you must live in Exile on
the moon of paraquat oh a paraquat
kumquat we must go to paraquat I also give to
you both our highest honor the key to plazier
awesome let's have a parade
quite a dark saver but we can let that go
now and to this little one I grant Knighthood
he's all kinds of things he's a Jedi
he's a Mandalorian he's a knight
go in peace Brave Travelers until I passed
meet again every season I'm a lady [Music]
it might just like sleep deprived
no this is this is a peculiar this
is a very strange based and weird I'm
having a blast but this is odd yes I'm
just gonna tie around to the stuff in the
beginning too they're going to follow you
I'm not their leader anymore Lex wolves is then
what's your play kill him dual DIN and win I'll
know when I get there oh no Follow My Lead
do what I do oh we're still going huh okay
this episode doesn't feel real no it's not
real it's this is this is all a fever dream
you're asleep you've been in the hospital for
weeks wake up man this feels like some weird
comic book I'm not command and going
quite fond of it then I challenge you
know this do you accept my challenge
not a [__] if that's what you're asking I do
this happens outside of Disney World all the
time by the way we shot this in a park nice
okay
yes oh man dough kill him she
has begaming looks all episode
watch out man wow this is a
well-produced fan film laughs
what they were able to bring together
with just a few friends in a public park
oh wow that was cool nice
yield
you won't even take the top Super for me oh
dingarin took the Creed and chose to walk the way
just as our ancestors did yeah he is every bit the
Mandalorian that they were certainly as much as
any of us ten times the king with fossa was the
ruler of Mandalore must possess the dark saber
then she shall have it give it to her
that's right that's a curse no just do it
curses aren't real buy it from me while
exploring Mandalore I was captured and this
blade was taken from me the technicality
she defeated the enemy that defeated me
yes that is literally a technicality and I'm
here for it this is the loophole [Laughter]
belong to her I've been hoping Bo did not
notice this it would Oh Captain My Captain
I returned this blade to its rightful
owner nice to the rebels pose
okay okay hello
[Music] hold it up
hold it up fried rice
wow that was this episode huh Johnny favs
yeah no this says John Favre original
I mean he craps out these scripts and he
wrote all the Mandalorian he wrote all of them
let's get him out which details did I put in which
show again oh crap oh God that was that was a lot
that was I mean it was it was fun I had a blast
yeah that was not jables I wouldn't say that was
her best work that straight up palazzos and Star
Wars Christopher Lloyd yeah this is a fat stack
of notable guests and then probably a bunch of
other like character and voice actors to boot
I felt like this was fake it was super fake the
not really happened it didn't it didn't feel
fake to me but it did feel like I peered into
an alternate universe where this was the sixth
episode of the third season Mandalorian and the
Multiverse of Madness sure man what happened here
this season has been eight different shows
smushed into one this was and I haven't hated it
but man oh man this episode in particular though
was something this was mcclunky all right clunky
we were border we got something else there oh
let's talk about it all right John you seem to
be the most positive take it away uh yeah I had
a blast I will not try and cover up the idea that
this does feel like a kind of a an incongruous
note I'm I'm a little torn I mean like you know
part of this journey over the entire course the
show has been a nomadic one has been sort of
bopping between different things but yes as we've
crested into season three it certainly feels like
things are struggling to decide whether they
want to be really serial or really episodic and
uh that stuff aside I don't know I I was very
Charmed by the Oddball uh quality of this uh I
can't pretend that it's strangeness of tone does
not uh you know undercut some tension or or you
know some of the just I don't know quality
of the overarching thing that's happening
or trying to happen but I don't know that I
had a blast with this I just I can't really
just say otherwise uh yeah I don't know I
like this whole investigating the droids
who are you know going haywire and Jack
Black and lizzo doing their you know
Royal folk and uh and then you know Christopher
uh uh Lloyd looking like he's about to fall over
and die or else uh yeah I don't know I was very
Charmed despite uh what this is in totality but
yeah that's that's my that's my two cents Michael
I know you want to get in there buddy Shrek in
space tell me that wasn't do lock like do lock
is a perfect place it is and so is wherever the
hell we just were for the past yeah 40 something
minutes uh no I mean it was it was super weird uh
uh I mean listen I'd be lying if I said I didn't
love every single millisecond of the chaos uh but
from like uh like as a producer as somebody
who's had to like write and and like bring
to life a feature film um there has been like a
blatant disregard for uh I think a comprehensive
cohesive narrative uh and I think you're able to
get away with that to an extent um I've kind of
reached the point and maybe this is a hot take and
I think this is like my first negative hot take uh
it's time it's time oh here comes I could feel
the people cracking the knuckles getting ready
to comment I feel like Marvel struggled from a
similar Affliction where all of a sudden it became
like a oh we're just gonna throw in these cameos
to the degree where they kind of lose their their
nuance and and any fun that there is to them like
I I like a good little Cameo I think it's great
when it's like oh turns out that Stormtrooper was
James Bond like that's pretty neat I think like I
could have handled Jack Black I could have handled
lizzo I could have handled Christopher Lloyd I
couldn't handle all three of them in this same
episode to the point where it took me out of the
narrative and and you know Greg you had a comment
earlier like yeah it kind of did feel like a fan
film and I think a lot of this season uh has been
that and you know part of me is like well that's
what we've been asking for right like we we want
something that's made by the fans for the fans
um but I feel like there there does come a point
where it starts to do a little bit of Injustice
to the story and I felt like they had some
really interesting beats in this episode that
I would have loved to just like sink our teeth
into I mean I think there was something really
interesting about you know playing with this idea
of like oh the Empire treated former separatist
planets in like a really awful way and there's
implications to that um but instead of like that
we got whatever this really interesting silly fun
thing was um you know I mean and there's a lot of
pieces that like who knows maybe they'll have a
payoff like the opening with with the the the mon
cow love affair like what was going where is that
could like you know it's just to recontextualize
ax's gang as as a more no like hard line group
now under his watch it's just breaking up I
don't think that romance is ever coming back
no well but like in the Star Wars fan of me is
like well moncal is like where you could build an
incredible Fleet which could come in handy for the
Mandalorian sweater and so but like I I just don't
know where we're going and we're now at the point
like an episode like this if you're gonna get this
off the rails do it really really early on I feel
like we're way too late in the game to be going on
this sort of misadventure but that being said Greg
your opinion is the one that really matters here
yeah sure uh as you are holding the the baby conch
I have said many times that Mandalorian is
my most favorite thing Star Wars has done
um did I have fun I know what I hate did
I have fun watching this sure did I have
fun for the reasons they intended though
that is the ultimate question this is like
it felt like a b movie it felt like a fan film
none of it when I say it doesn't feel real I'm
like I don't it's not that I don't feel like
we're stepping into a fever dream it feels like
all this feel Everything feels fake to me none
of it feels truly it's the question it is like
there's something about this that just doesn't
feel lived in it and I I kind of experienced
that a little bit more with some of these episodes
of season three so far and this took like forever
to come out so I thought this wouldn't be an issue
yeah but there is something especially with unless
it takes place in like some dark ass place there
there's something with its tone and it's pacing
and it's lighting where none of it a lot of the
time it just doesn't feel real anymore and I
would never say that about season one and two it
was the exact opposite about season one and two
like look how I feel like I'm I get to live
in this world again and then here everything
just feels artificial to me and this episode in
particular yeah I had fun because I was laughing
at the episode this I was laughing at it I don't
feel like like the the way they treat you could
have Bill Burr in here and it's it's really
believable yeah he's great as Mayfield He's
phenomenal as Mayfield Jack Black was like this
is a sketch now and there is seriously no tension
no Stakes we are zipping across everywhere in
this random City and and then we try to tie
it back in into what feels like the equivalent
of kids who love making a fan film in the park
we were all once one of those kids we're live
in Los Angeles there's all of us here go to the
park tomorrow you'll see them I don't know
what happened here and Bryce Dallas Howard
made this episode and I don't think it's a
Bryce Dallas Howard problem it's something
going on with the mouse house I I I and I
I'm gonna chime in there because I've I've
got a hunch uh I think that there finally
really was a genuine master plan that was
being put into action by Favreau and felony
and I think a big part of that was going to
be several of these spin-off shows the ranch is
the new Republic and there's just been episodes
that are like so clearly what that show was
supposed to be I mean I would be surprised
if if they genuinely wrote grogu out as
they intended and then were told you know
had bad episodes because when they were
boring yeah this wasn't boring no this was
you really don't have a thought oh I wasn't
cueing body language to be like let me jump in
here the only thought lingering on my mind right
now is just that like everything you did in this
episode I think or at least the multiple things
they tried to do in this episode could easily
have each filled like you could have had the Droid
problem with lizzo and Jack Blackbeard's whole own
thing you could have the droids and what they're
going through as a community of sentient beings
and that be its own thing and then you could
have the re uh Distributing of the dark saber
earning back the respect of the fleet all that
could have been its own story in episode that
just shouldn't have been an afterthought this
was so ridiculous that was uh that is I don't
mind the choice of of them finally finding a
way around a duel but in this episode that is
like a legitimate gripe yeah we're just taking
care of this in like a three minute chat yeah
after that like look at this terrifying
conversation between the armorer and bow and
this like really spooky like think about where
we left the last episode the dark tone of of
blue discovering the empty Imperial shuttle yeah
then to whatever this was you know and I think
and and here's the critique like I totally agree
with your note about the it being lived in uh or
or not being lived in in this case and that was
something that I think people really fell in love
with Star Wars because it was so textured because
it was this retro futuristic like really fun uh
it made it so it wasn't all shiny and glossy and
to George Lucas's credit when he did the prequels
I still think he managed to achieve a sense
of oh this is lived in but it's still new and
shiny and it can be ornate whatever this is now
is neither like the prequel or the original in
in terms of what it provides not even the Disney
sequels no it's literally quantumania I mean like
the the and I love Guardians I'm saying this feels
like a I think we're I think you and I at least
are like this feels like there's a production
problem that happened with this season yeah so
I could see that sure yeah well because they got a
lot of the same returning directors and and filoni
is I mean he's credited as writing and I know he's
involved but uh but I know he's also spearheading
the Ahsoka show there's there's but there's
a magic when you put those two together and
like favro and it was like well they balance each
other out in such an important way because I think
you know both of them are such talented creatives
but like I mean I think speaking you know with my
producer writer hat on for a minute like there's
certain projects that like sure I could try to do
it by myself but if I do it without like my proper
creative Partners it's gonna be off the roads and
you know I think the the problem um and this is
the same issue that Marvel has in my opinion is
you get to a point where like yeah you can only
like stretch out Kevin foggy like Gumby for so
long before he rips into pieces uh and it's it's
not a critique of of the creatives as as much as
it is you know I mean they have enormous pressure
on them right now as as the flagship series for
Disney plus to deliver and I think in the process
uh they've been set up to fail it doesn't even
feel like it's about denjarn anymore well and and
I could be fine I could be fine with that choice I
think the problem is it doesn't know what it wants
it does yeah it doesn't replace it with something
more interesting and focused yeah and listen I
love Beau I love the Clone Wars ARC I love all
that stuff I cannot like believe that the build-up
of Bo winning back her Mandalorian compatriots and
getting the dark saber is going to be written
off in the last five minutes yeah that's [__]
it's not fair it's it's not fair and like the and
honestly kudos to those in the comments section
because everybody called out the technicality
but like no offense to our comment section but
one would hope that the writers that are paid lots
of lots of lots of money to think something out
would maybe go a little bit deeper than than what
we all came to the conclusion of uh immediately
thereafter like did didn't intentionally
wait till they were in front of people
and now I'll do this technicality speech and let
people get sick of this and then I'll make my move
yeah yeah and and you you set up a character
that we had like what five minutes with to
to I know just what is happening with this show
listen they've how many episodes do we have left
uh two oh no yeah I've never been worried
for this show but yeah when you got to hear
when this is be such a pivotal episode and they
turned this in and Bryce Dallas Howard directed
it I'm like something else is going wrong
here and because I know I just know for a
fact I know a lot of the people who already
mattered has probably already clicked off
I know there's gonna be people who are
like it feels like a Clone Wars episode
and I say this is somebody that's
watched it three times through
there's still Arts there are still rules that
they follow I think this is like if you took
one episode out of like four different Clone Wars
arcs and then just damaged them right there they
just jammed it into one which which like frankly
what this felt like in my mind was like season one
or two have flown yes yeah like there's there's
no excuse for the third season of a show of this
magnitude and this much talent you know I'm I'm
I'm really I'm gonna be cautiously optimistic I
think that we have to remember this season of
Mandalorian is the last of the jpeg debacle uh
in terms of The reigns of Disney being handed back
over here it's like two years was this affected by
covet I mean had to be I mean everything's been
affected by covet but maybe that's what they're
always going out of their way of being like we
already wrote season four it's all planned out
jpeg though I think I mean this is like the
epitome of why they they gave him the boot is
for this kind of mismanagement but I mean honestly
and I hate to like beat the drum on this and like
listen I I'm I'm forever appreciative to Kathleen
Kennedy for her contribution to film and TV God
knows she played an important role in all the
films that I loved growing up um but I think it's
it's genuinely time to like if this is going to be
a marvel-esque property that we take seriously the
flagship show cannot do what they did this episode
yeah um and you know I I think there's there's so
many I mean the whole just like play this out
in your head for a sec this entire series its
entire purpose thus far has been to try to explain
the lack of cohesive storytelling that went into
the sequel Trilogy like every single action with
the grogu and it turned to cloning and all these
different connective threads are trying to make
up for the lack of cohesion that that landed them
into this debacle in the first place and what I'm
seeing is no lessons have been learned I really
that's why I like the third episode because it's
like these are choices and plots and fetch quests
that are being driven by emotional choices and a
good narrative even even people were like oh I'm
a fan of that third episode of Pershing I'm like
I think this exceptionally better than what this
one is by far I love the second episode and out
of all these episodes I'm like I like the others
and I I but like the what the faults that I would
find with the others it all came to like a massive
culmination in this one and when you have eight
episodes like okay I can't just settle for like
B movie fun after a while like I had fun watching
it but I was certainly laughing at it and not and
not and it didn't feel like it was intentionally
supposed to laugh with it sorry John we have been
talking so much oh it's a weird episode what's
more to really say I mean I just find that very
entertaining but like I can't really disagree
with almost anything you guys have brought up
here and I think that yeah if the sheer amount
of guest stars too it's like I think you could
have made Jack Black and lizzo work uh if we had a
little bit more time with that and a little better
ways to Tamper the humor there and then you have
Christopher Lloyd who's like you know he's not
just gonna be selling Cameo and it's probably not
going to be these two lovebirds over here so like
yeah I don't know yeah I'm not even I've never
complained about this show cinematography but
I've noticed like lately it's just everything's
so freaking bright and and it just feels like
actors in front of a green screen now or the
volume it just looks like actors in front of
a volume and like the sets generally don't truly
feel like someone they went to the city it did
it reminded me a lot of uh uh uh the cannabite
Cantina uh sequence and sure SQL trailer it's just
very like what this isn't it's Star Wars it didn't
and Vogue play was this weird Dynamics to me it
was a little weird dynamic their chemistry needed
something else then it needed some more time
together or or something in a more serious tone
because it's just a weird I can I'm completely
there with you and I love both of them I mean I
think I love them both individually yeah exactly
um no I mean frankly the the only stuff that's
like really had like dramatic tone and like
really been I think down to earth uh I've really
enjoyed the armor sequences sure which is crazy
because not a character that should have that
much emotional weight but like I love the tension
that I feel there and um I don't know I we we know
what they're capable of and I think that's what's
disappointing uh and listen this would have made
a great holiday special it felt like that well and
that I mean too I feel like we didn't really have
any time to at least in other episodes or other
Star Wars media where they have introduced like oh
hey we're having a feast or something or you're on
a new world granted I mean you're living in the
problem of their society being so Droid based and
all that stuff recommissioned blah blah but yeah
it's like when you join them at this banquet thing
maybe I don't know unpack a little bit of what the
significance of this is or what cultural you know
element it is serving in one way or another rather
than just yes a bright garish excuse to have a
bunch of recognizable Star Wars species he's in
one room together or something like that yeah
um this is sad it's like yeah it's like it's
a sci-fi movie hodgepodge at a certain point
yeah I mean they were like like we said earlier
it was like Star Trek Star Trek Vibes but like
like the knock right episodes of Next Generation
yeah like like I got a lot of that uh and there's
certainly no shortage of like doctor it was
just weird it was it was like a low budget
I yeah it felt like what happened to your money
yeah why does the front door looks so much better
that they burned it all on mandolin like that I
mean that's cinematography in in the the mind I
know Mandalore that was where it went they're
like they've used too much of the jet packs
it's it adds up Chris yeah it's like I feel like
now the Mandalorian is becoming a show to set up
other people and other shows which is not again
lessons not learned it just feels like din jar
and it's but especially kuroku but it's hard and
Croaker are just walking through the show for like
other people's yeah they literally just happened
to be there which has always happened but yeah it
doesn't have that Kung Fu Essence no it doesn't
have that Mad Max Essence yeah and even I mean
what a lost opportunity with with bow and den to
create some tension between would-be Ally like
there was a room for really interesting character
development and growth for for Bo to put her
people above her own ambition and instead she just
got handed everything she could have ever wanted
um oh God that's so that's that is so
silly to me this was so silly well there's
just enough episodes left to either
break our hearts or change our minds
I'm genuinely concerned the next two will be
two hours a piece that's how they'll make up
honestly I'd be cool if they if they said we're
gonna pause We're not gonna put out the next two
episodes and we're gonna take the next two to
three years to get our stuff together I will
continue to pay for my Disney Plus subscription
in the meantime like ah God anyway guys oh man
what did you think I know it was fun but be honest
with yourself what do you think I like the reject
Nation a lot because we generally even if we're
negative we tend to attract the ones who are
optimistic and positive and I love that about the
reject Nation yeah I do too it's generally tends
to be the top comments of like I had fun and I
I support that and I encourage them and that's
what that's what TV and Star Wars is at the end
of the day I guess I guess my Hope was that the
bar might be raised just a little tiny bit yep
all right guys well thanks for being here tell
us your thoughts you excited for thrawn to show
up in a hilarious episode of the Mandalorian
[Laughter]
all right let's send this with a patreon
Lance door listen if anybody could fix
this it's you buddy you're already out
there helping the people of Canada stay safe
from all sorts of natural disasters come in
and fix the disaster that has become lucasfilm
I'm sure that you with your No Nonsense and your
holistic approach could probably come up
with some kind of a you know interesting
hook for the writers to follow and then
from there you will be the savior of the
new Republic of all of the people of the Star
Wars Galaxy you could unite them all under one
umbrella of good storytelling Lance and if not I
mean I think if you just like you know took off
your shirt put on a Mandalorian helmet you know
and oil down your chest a little bit I mean you
can make everybody forget that any of this ever
happened I'd buy that calendar yeah and then get
Bryce Dallas Howard to shoot the pictures of
the calendar so they'll look as good as they
possibly can and then both her directing career
which has been polished as of this episode will
be will be mended you know and then you will
rise as the hero we always truly deserve to lead
us into a new age so stay safe out there Lance
because you got a lot of responsibility riding
on your shoulders I have spoken this is the way
maintain your pledge we love you buddy love you